-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well,
and now if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin announced yesterday
that he opposes
President Biden's nominee
for the Federal Reserve board,
before adding,
"But out of curiosity,
who is it?"
[ Laughter ]
The White House said yesterday
that national security adviser
Jake Sullivan had a 7-hour
conversation
with a top Chinese
diplomat in Rome.
I hate to be the one
to tell you this,
but seven hours
is a breakup talk.
No one -- no one's ever said,
"Well, my girlfriend and I
were up talking all night,
and she loves the way
I load the dishwasher, and
everything is going great."
[ Laughter ]
Tesla CEO Elon Musk yesterday
challenged Russian President
Vladimir Putin
to "single combat."
Oh, come on, give me
somebody to root for.
[ Laughter ]
This is like hearing
the New York Yankees
want to play against Duke.
[ Laughter ]
Iowa Senator Chuck Grassley
said recently
that Senate Republicans
will be fair and thorough
during the upcoming
confirmation hearings
for Supreme Court nominee
Ketanji Brown Jackson.
And added, "We're not going
to get in the gutter
like the Democrats did."
Though, to be fair,
they only got in the gutter
because that's where
Brett Kavanaugh passed out,
so...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Mayor Eric Adams joined the
social media platform
TikTok yesterday
and said in his first video,
"Bing bong, New York City,
your mayor is on TikTok.
Let's get stuff done."
Okay.
Being on TikTok is what we do
when we don't want
to get stuff done.
That's like saying,
"We got a lot of work to do,
somebody fire up Elden Ring."
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Eric Adams
joined TikTok yesterday
and said in his first video,
"Bing bong, New York City."
Oh, boy.
If Eric Adams
was New York City's dad,
we'd be asking him to drop us
off two blocks away from school.
"Your friends
will love bing bong."
"Just, no!"
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
trained ants may be effective
in detecting cancer in humans,
or at least more effective
than others.
It's cancer.
Whatever you're typing in
right now, it's cancer.
[ Laughter ]
Country legend Dolly Parton
announced yesterday
that she will remove her name
from the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame ballot.
But Dolly is not
going to like this.
They're replacing her
on the ballot with Jolene.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
Head writer Alex Baze and I had
a conversation
right before this show.
We had no idea how that joke
was going to go.
[ Laughter ]
I will say, of the many ways
we thought,
that wasn't one of them.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, in honor
of St. Patrick's day,
Krispy Kreme will release
four new flavors of doughnuts.
Though if you really want
to honor the Irish,
I think you do no flavor.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
I mean, to make a St. Patrick's
Day joke that's not about
alcoholism
and is about bad cooking,
I think that shows
some real restraint.
[ Laughter ]
That was the monologue,
everybody.